to pick someone to start with a key
almost always blame the mouse i like the
nickname so let's start
just just before until until i've
started blaming the mouse
so what's what's going on previous time
previously i was trying to read youtube
the youtube chat but uh also
twitch chat but i don't think now i'll
be able to do the same
okay this is a dragon let's take
and okay let's try five there is knight
g8 i think
i think this is the move yep
and now okay i don't know anymore what
to do you maybe have four
shame on me but i don't know any theory
here just
a couple of common moves maybe this one
seems bad to me already here so
maybe i'm not losing maybe i'm not not
yet losing
i'm not just losing as i was losing
against an ish at least
so now let's say we can
we can testify any position we just can
compare it with my mesh against anish
and
we say either position is good or not
good enough for bad or
losing or not losing or somewhere is
between
in between so can i castle
there there is a pin there is a pin
so
okay i actually i have just wanted
bishop g4
but fortunately well i mean okay i'm
just i just keep playing
as badly as i played against finish so
everything is all right
it's it's me it's me yeah it's just me
everything is all right okay let's try
e6
in advance i would say that my play is
not going to be impressive tonight
on the country i'll play like
like a big big [ __ ] so probably a lot
of guys
will will beat me today but okay let's
see if maybe i can
turn the tables somehow
okay now i'm turning this one this
particular table is going to be turned
okay just centralizing not blundering
not anymore
focused
on finding some brilliant optimal moves
okay let's just trade everything let's
just start everything good
again it's good all in game i'm not
going through it for sure
maybe i haven't tried to win
well what he doesn't want he doesn't
want to trade
so again then i give him a check
and i promote luke 6d5
it's time to pay your debts you don't
want to beat me
and now you join an issue in this
set list
yeah so now i feel like i'm pressing
finally
he has queen b3 probably yeah just to
queen d3 just to save the day but uh i
mean not setting the game but
making you making it a little bit longer
i don't see if i if i can avoid
going straight maybe maybe i actually
can but
i'm not sure if i want to
so let's wait for a move
c5 is the move all right so let's take
let's take give a check and win a rook
okay resize thank you all this blade in
the mouse
i had several reasons during this game
uh several moments to blame the mouse
but
fortunately it was all right event